[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien on débat sur france 24 une page se
tourne après neuf ans de lutte
antiterroriste la france et ses
partenaires européens annoncent leur
retrait militaire du mali mais affirme
vouloir rester engagés au sahel et dans
les pays du golfe de guinée cette
annonce a lieu en marge d'un sommet
union européenne union africaine à
bruxelles un sommet qui vise à changer
la donne des relations entre africains
et européens alors quel va être l'impact
du redéploiement sécuritaire de la
france et des européens au sahel quel
rôle joue la chine et la russie dans la
région que devient le sahel fasse une
redistribution des cartes sécuritaire et
géopolitique on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés antoine glaser bonsoir journaliste
écrivain spécialiste de l'afrique
hauteur du piège africains de macron en
face de vous voici menace rebonjour
voici ma journaliste france 24
spécialiste des réseaux jihadistes
bienvenue dans le débat tiny vircoulon
est à côté de vous bonsoir chercheur
associé au centre afrique de l'ifri
bonsoir et bienvenue également et puis
en face de vous auto ma agassi ou un bon
soir député agir ensemble membre de la
commission de la défense nationale et
des forces armées également membre de la
mission d'information sur l'opération
abarkan alors avant de démarrer ce débat
je vous propose de faire un petit point
en images avec axel ciment
confirmé véritable casse tête logistique
le retrait s'étalera sur une durée de
quatre à six mois d'après le président
de la république
il sera effectuée de manière ordonnée
avec les forces armées maliennes et avec
la mission des nations unies au mali
durant cette période nous maintiendrons
nos missions de soutien au profit de la
minus mans concrètement les trois bases
de gao gossip et ménaka seront donc vidé
soit 2400 soldats français de
l'opération barkan qui participe depuis
2014 à la trappe des groupes jihadistes
dans le sahel au delà de barkan le
retrait français va également entraîner
la fin des forces spéciales takouba
créé il ya moins de deux ans les
militaires européens y participant
seront repositionnées dans la région
frontalière du mali
avec l'accord des autorités nigériennes
des éléments européens seront
repositionnées aux côtés des forces
armées nigériennes dans la région
frontalière du mali
paris réaffirme toutefois vouloir rester
engagé avec les européens auprès des
pays sahéliens et du golfe de guinée
pour poursuivre la lutte contre le
terrorisme aux côtés du président
ghanéen et du conseil européen le
président sénégalais présents à la
conférence de presse a indiqué
comprendre la décision française nous
avons convenu aveugle que la lutte conte
le serbe contre le terrorisme au sahel
ne serait être la seule affaire de pays
africains et l'abc sans consensus
que un engagement a été renouvelée de
rester dans la région de l'est de l'inde
dispositif
paris a promis de coordonner son retrait
non seulement avec la mission de l'onu
au mali la minus ma mais aussi avec la
mission de formation de l'union
européenne au mali le utm qui
continueront de bénéficier d'un soutien
aérien et médical français sur place
avant le transfert ultérieur et
définitive de ses moyens
et on va écouter tout de suite le chef
d'état major pascal ya ni au micro de
cyril payen et de franck alexandre
alors c'est effectivement une décision
significative qu'on peut qualifier
d'historique puisque nous sommes engagés
au mali depuis 2013 mais comme l'a
précisé le président de république on ne
parle pas d'échec et nous récusons le
terme d'échec deux défaites
d'humiliation de déroute comme on a pu
l'entendre ou le lire au cours d'eau
cours des dernières semaines la décision
qui a été prise
correspond à un état de fait et cet état
de fait il est imposé par
les autorités de transition et par la
jeune malienne c'est la responsabilité
de la junte malienne ce qui est en train
de se passer c'est elle qui porte la
responsabilité ce ne sont pas les armées
françaises
porte-parole du chef d'état-major vous
aurez plus à le voir pascal yannick
antoine glaser weil macron récuse
totalement l'idée d'un échec français
france at elle perdu la guerre contre le
terrorisme non on n'a pas perdu la
guerre contre le terrorisme et l'échec
de barca n'est avéré puisque même les
militaires le 10 10 aux mains avec dix
opérations serval t bonds une réussite
tout le monde s'est jeté sur un seul
pays à empêcher les djihadistes de
descente moi je pense pas qu'ils
auraient pris la capitale bamako enfin
ils ont réprimé toute une partie du pays
et bien évidemment que ensuite ce que
disent assez mais bof les militaires il
avoue maintenant ils disent c'est vrai
que ont cédé c'est dans l'euphorie de
l'opération servent à vaincre et barkan
qui est une une armée conventionnelle et
on voit bien d'ailleurs que emmanuel
macron lui-même très vite il s'est rendu
compte que cette armée conventionnelle à
l'ancienne à la françafrique avec ses
convois avec les drapeaux français dans
le sahel offshore alors que finalement
les états ne remplissent plus leur
prérogatives régaliennes justice et tout
dans ces trucs il a vu qu'il a voulu
créer takouba j'ai souvent des forces
spéciales invisible qu'on ne voit pas
tout ce qu'il veut faire maintenant mais
ok mais barkan fallait bien abandonner
sa bouche alors il ya ceux qui pensent
même que ça c'est le fait qu'il ya des
diatribes avec la jeune malienne ça
facilite finalement le retrait de barkan
parfois ce qu'il nie le il dit sa
richesse est difficile il d'abord c'est
un truc dont il a hérité c'est pas lui
qui a qu'à monter barkan et très
franchement c'est tu comme un gros
bateau qu'à continuer totalement hors
sol par rapport aux réalités du terrain
et par rapport à ouvrer lutte
antiterroriste au bout d'un moment les
gens se demandaient qu'est ce que barkan
faisait dans le sahel puisque il n'y
avait pas les résultats allaient
malheureusement il s'est quand même 53
soldats français ont été tués et au bout
d'un moment on s'est dit mais barkan
c'est même franchement of même les
militaires français qui étaient dehors
vraiment au coeur de ces opérations et
10 c'est vrai on sait on était dans
l'euphorie l'euphorie de la france qui
se croient toujours chez elle en afrique
dans cette euphorie on a laissé comme ça
c'est invincible armada qui et pathé par
vinci pas invincible wassim quand on ne
gagne pas la guerre on la perd bah c'est
pas c'est pas vraiment en fait
l'engagement militaire a atteinte des
objectifs qui lui ont été et qui ont été
mis c'est leur problème c'est la
capitalisation politique derrière sur
l'opération militaire savez quand on est
enfermé dans une guerre contre le
terrorisme
une guerre contre un mode opératoire
c'est une guerre sans fin y a pas
d'objectif à la guerre ça veut dire les
militaires français savait pas quand
est-ce que ils ont gagné la guerre est
ce que c'est en tuant des chefs est ce
que c'est en faisant reculer les
djihadistes est ce que quand les
djihadistes la soirée paieront les
djihadistes aide mais ils n'ont pas été
battus là on parle et je suis d'accord
avec avec antoine que l'objectif de
prendre bamako je pense pas qu'il était
dans les ogives des djihadistes parce
que déjà une grande ville comme ça vous
n'avez pas de soutien il y aurait pu la
prendre mais aujourd'hui alors qu'on
parle ils sont en train de faire des
opérations la dialyse pas très loin de
bamako donc est ce que l'objectif
recherché a été atteint mais nous
manquer voilà donc opérations militaires
il fallait capitaliser là dessus c'est
au moment où par exemple droukdel a été
tué la police a été tué ou du moment où
on a la filiale les saoudiens d'al qaïda
qui dit la gare avec la france c'est au
sahel on touche pas au territoire
français ça veut dire que grâce à la
pression était française ce sont des
objets utilitaires qui aurait pu être
capitaux pour l'un pu capitaliser autour
politiquement pour les maliens c'est
pareil les maliens ils ont perdu un
nombre très important de militaires
pendant les occasions mais ils ont pas
su réinvestir les endroits qu'ils ont
repris aux djihadistes pas que avec la
police et léa et l'armée mais avec les
services avec la justice et donc ils
n'ont pas su non plus capitaliser sur
leurs pertes militaires tomates via
cantatrice aurait pu durer encore très
longtemps il a perdu sa guerre ou pas
non je pense que déjà il faut redéfinir
ce qu'est la victoire aujourd'hui la
victoire fasciné remis symétrique c'est
obtenir la reddition et réduire cet
ermite fins un groupe armé jadis c'est
totalement différent je pense qu'il ya
trois points à mettre en oeuvre dans
l'objectif d' armée française 1 on a
évité la territorialisation de la menace
jihadiste comme on a pu la connaître en
zone irako syrienne en 2014 2 on a
réduit profondément profondément les
capacités des groupes armés terroristes
en neutralisant beaucoup de leurs chefs
en cassant les chaînes logistiques et 3
l'armée malienne qui était quasiment
inexistante en 2013 a aujourd'hui
davantage des capacités opérationnelles
en 2013 c'est d'être dix mille hommes
aujourd'hui ses 40 milles donc oui il
n'est pas encore assez performante mais
d'un point de vue militaire des
objectifs importants auront été atteints
ce qui manque aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement le relais de l'état malien
le fait que les accords de paix qui ont
été signés avance le fait que l'état se
redéploie sur le sur le terrain puisque
l'armée française n'a pas vocation à
être une armée de substitution antoine
glaser vont réagir sur ce qui est à dire
justement un ton agacé c'est pour ça que
c'est vrai que c'est pas une armée de
substitution est très souvent ça soit
même rang au niveau des de la jeunesse
africaine il y avait une sorte
d'anachronisme historique on a
l'impression que l'armée française étant
là avec l'armée française y avait tout
le dispositif intégré de la françafrique
à l'ancienne ce qui est ce qui n'est pas
le cas de victoire contre
exercer l'éducation dans cette victoire
contre lady a dit non vers les jaunards
brésil qui a 10 parce que le problème ce
n'est pas les djihadistes seulement
c'est des groupes armés en tous genres
c'est du trafic en tout genre et c'est
tout il ya dix ils ont déjà gagné ils
ont fait fuir les occidentaux depuis le
soudan depuis la mauritanie jusqu'au
soudan ya plus d'occidentaux dans cette
région et en l'occurrence au centre du
pays au centre dix minutes après après
elle est le personnel qui avait été
décrite par par monsieur gracieux c'est
que effectivement après la réunion de
porc en 2020 l'état islamique a été
contenue mais il a été aussi contenue à
la faveur de sa guerre avec al qaïda au
même moment où le jeune imam al qaîda
était se déployer dans le tissu sociétal
et dans le tissu local du manière assez
très politique donc c'est ça l'enjeu
aujourd'hui il ya un danger qu'ils
étaient dangers sécuritaires celui des
états islamiques et un danger politique
est celui d'al qaîda qui peut devenir
insécuritaire donc comment jongler avec
tout ça je voudrais dire que je nie
totalement le terme de françafrique
l'armée française est homogène avec
c'est à la demande des autorités
syriennes et le président macro n'a eu
de cesse de redemander lors des semelles
a demandé ça et bien premier point
seconde mans
l'évolution de barkan elle a déjà été
actée depuis un certain temps des le
semaine n'djamena le présent macron de
faire évoluer l'opération barkan vers
davantage de deux takouba avec
effectivement une empreinte plus légère
au sol moins de visibilité et davantage
de soutien aux forces locales lorsque je
parle de force afrique c'est l'impensé
de la françafrique ça veut dire dans la
jeunesse africaine ya l'impensé de la
françafrique et c'est certain que une
armée conventionnelle comme barkan c'est
pour ça que d'ailleurs malheureusement
que convoitent barkan sont fait
caillasser au burkina faso et au niger
parce que l'impensé animé par des
réseaux sociaux autant en france que sur
le terrain c'est la réalité du terrain
tiens à dire que l'on vous aviez écrit
que la france ne se retirerait pas du
mali l'année dernière il me semble dans
un article vous avez été surpris de ce
retrait du coup je n'ai jamais écrit que
la france se retire et pas du mali mais
j'ai au contraire écrit que non
seulement elle se retire du mali mais
elle risque de se retirer d'autres pays
contrairement à ce qu'annonce le
président de la république puisqu'en
fait l'acceptabilité ou l'acceptation
populaire de cette mission et de la
présence de l'armée française pas
simplement de la mission barkan mais la
présence de l'armée française dans tout
le sahel
n'existe quasiment plus en fait là on
parle de guerre la guerre n'a pas été
perdue premièrement parce qu'elle n'est
pas terminée qu'elle risque d'ouvrir
malheureusement encore longtemps mais
surtout mais ce qui est très important à
mon sens c'est qu'elle est perdue dans
l'opinion publique sahélienne l'opinion
publique israélienne rejette la présence
de l'armée française c'est pas parce que
les chefs d'état au niger notamment ou
au sénégal etc disent maintenant devant
la tribune qu' ils sont ravis que les
militaires français se redéploie dans
leur zone que leurs populations leçons
et ça c'est très grave parce que l'armée
française où les autorités politiques
françaises plutôt ont perdu la bataille
des coeurs et des esprits quoi on dit
tout simplement parce souviennent
l'accueil justement il ya on est passé
d'un accueil triomphal aux
manifestations anti françaises devant
les ambassades de la zone tout
simplement parce que
l'insécurité s'est répandue on dit on a
gagné la bataille contre les djihadistes
mais le terrain maintenant n'est pas
simplement une question de djihadistes
il y a une carte des acteurs de
l'insécurité qui est quasiment un
faisable parce qu'ils ont proliféré ils
se sont multipliés et la vie enfin la
vérité pas la vérité mais on quand on
regarde la dynamique conflictuelle
depuis plusieurs années on se rend
compte que l'armée française est dépassé
par cette dynamique l'armée française
n'a qu'un seul objectif c'est de tuer
des djihadistes comme on le disait mais
à côté d'eux il y à une prolifération
milices locales il y à une guerre civile
au mali qui ne dit pas son nom et celle
ci il a débordé sur le nord du burkina
faso maintenant donc il y à une
situation conflictuelle qui est
ingérable et qui est
qui pour les populations sahéliennes et
le premier choc qu'elles prennent et qui
reste le lire maintenant que nous tuions
eux subissent des psa sera d'accueillir
avec leurs très justement des français
et des européens alors au mali on va
voir ce qui va se passer sur le plan
sécuritaire et on va voir surtout
comment les russes peuvent remplir le
vide qui va en effet être créés les
russes et d'autres d'ailleurs on peut
passer aux algériens on peut penser aux
turcs etc on va voir donc comment ça va
se passer au mali mais ce qui est
certain c'est que à partir du moment où
en effet il n'y aura plus
d'interventions directes et cinétique
comme on dit à l'armée sur le territoire
malien soit d'autres acteurs étrangers
d'autres puissances étrangères devront
le faire soit en effet sa débordera
encore plus sur les autres pays de la
région on va revenir justement sur ces
autres pays mais avant ces atomes agassi
ou six mois pour se retirer totalement
manifestement c'est ça c'est court donc
oui six mois c'est court mais si vous me
le permettez je trouve qu'on focalise
beaucoup sur l'armée française
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur un problème
bilatéral entre la france et le mali
mais sur un premier entre le mali et
l'ensemble de ses partenaires ses
partenaires africains et les partenaires
européens ce ne sont pas que les
français qui ont subi des entraves ce
sont également les danois c'est
également la minus la deuxième chose
quand vous êtes une armée étrangère que
vous intervenez dans un pays
effectivement vous vous arrivez toujours
en libérateur mais dans les yeux du pays
vous finissez toujours au bout d'un
certain temps il ya une fatalité d'être
vu comme une armée d'occupation quelle
que soit la qualité ont fait été de
sortir avant moi j'ai préconisé dès 2020
de rester autrement c'est-à-dire
d'alléger notre empreinte c'est ce qu'a
proposé présent macro n'djamena et de
faire davantage de takouba et moins de
barkan c'est à dire d'être invisible en
premier et davantage en appui pour
justement lutter contre ce sentiment
qu'on a une armée de substitution aux
forces maliennes alors qu'on est là on
aurait dû être une armée davantage pour
appuyer les forces maliennes wassim
justement ça pose la question sur la
présence de la minus m'a également donc
quid de cette présence 14 mille
militaires et policiers sur place il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes pas à part la
présence aussi la minustah ne profite
pas de l'appui aérien de la france elle
pourra pas opérer d'une manière assez
efficace sur le terrain sachant qu' il
faut rappeler c'est
la mission de l'onu la plus meurtrière
aujourd'hui la maison après un lourd
très lourd tribut dans cette danse est
guère que ce soit des armées africaines
que ce soit l'armée égyptienne l'armée
togolaise même les allemands se sont
pris un attentat suicide il ya quelques
il ya quelques mois de ça une version
ben non c'est pas encore les allemands
ont dit que peut-être il se retirer par
exemple pour faire voler leurs drones
les allemands ont besoin sont obligés
maintenant de donner un préavis de 36
heures aux autorités maliennes donc ce
sont aussi des entraves que les
autorités maliennes aujourd'hui pose à
cette force sachant que par exemple les
évocations médical ou say say say say
l'armée bilingue qui en profitent en
premier de donc ça c'est c'est un grand
questionnement aujourd'hui et c'est la
question qui se pose aussi parce que le
retrait au sol est-ce que ça va être
jugé par une interdiction de vol pour
les armées françaises on m'a dit ça on
le sait pas encore et donc si la
tradition de voile encore une fois et
l'amusement ne profite plus de l'appui
aérien français ça sera encore une autre
une autre paire de manches tiens
vircoulon ça risque tout de même de
manquer peut-être aux maliens cette mini
cement pas tellement content couteller
leur opinion sur la minus ma parce que
son opérationnalité quand même très
faible et elle a surtout un rôle
politique plus que militaire son avenir
se jouera au conseil de sécurité donc ça
va concerner les membres du conseil de
sécurité quelques mois et on voit mal
ses membres demandez-leur le départ de
cette mission il faut se rappeler que
par exemple la monusco existe au congo
depuis 1999 mais pourquoi est ce qu'on
ne retire pas assez de le symbole c'est
la présence politique malgré ces voix là
c'est un symbole politique c'est parce
qu'il ya un consensus au niveau du
conseil de sécurité où on préfère
dépenser un milliard par an elle donc
avoir une solution politique
donc voila et mais je pense que l'otan
lui utile m évidemment une mission
européenne va partir parce que c'était
quand même la france qui élit donné shon
sur sur langage mission opération c'est
une mission de formation les avions
quand même
les allemands
partiront aussi il faut quand même être
clair c'était la france qui joue le rôle
de l'hymne les chaînes au sahel pour les
européens et à partir du moment où il ya
une crise diplomatique entre paris et
bamako les européens en pâtissent
antoine
cube à la fin de la france est la nation
cadre moi je pense toute façon c'est un
changement d'époque qui correspond à une
réalité de terrain c'est vraiment
maintenant le mali des médias et
l'afrique des africains et donc on est
dans une période vraiment historique
c'est pas simplement le retrait de
barkan s'aimer même si on sent bien
d'ailleurs le président macron on voit
bien c'est un cissé s'est pas trop va là
on va aller d'abord d'un pays voisin
déjà il faut sortir des jalles et les
militaires de marc khanne peut-être sans
doute par le niger de façon intéresse
mais gère ça prend du temps c'est
dangereux et caetera et c'est un retour
vers les côtes c'est un retour vers les
côtes ce matin le président emmanuel
macron il parlait de l'initiative acres
à accra c'est une initiative avec le
ghana le burkina faso la côte d'ivoire
le togo c'est le retour sur les côtes à
l'ancienne et le dernier drapeau
français ça sera celui du tchad parce
que ça c'est là où l'armée deux bastions
l'armée française
alors quel va être l'impact de ce
retrait en tout cas français et
européens sur la sécurité au sahel on va
écouter le président sénégalais
président de l'union africaine macky
sall qui lui s'inquiétant de ce retrait
la lutte contre le terrorisme est devenu
depuis plus d'une décennie
un défi majeur pour l'afrique
nous ne voulons pas que le continent
devienne le ventre mou du terrorisme
international
c'est pourquoi nous souhaitons ardemment
pour suivre nos partenaires européens
les efforts solidaire déjà engagé de
longue date que nous avons toujours
salut thomas gueydier or ce qui est sûr
c'est que le président macky sall mais
également alassane ouattara eux se
disent qu'une sécurité uniquement
africaine ce ne sera pas suffisant face
à la baisse jihadiste a je pense que la
demande est claire il y avait également
le le président de la cedeao en exercice
qui demande à la france de rester de
continuer son accueil à la france et aux
européens et si aujourd'hui il ya un
repositionnement avec l'épicentre au
niger mais repositionnement qui avait
déjà commencé qui avait déjà été annoncé
aux semaines de neige amène à c'est
aussi que la menace se déplace vers le
sud les grandes international jadis
n'ont pas fait mystère de leur volonté
de s'étendre en afrique de l'ouest de
faire la jonction avec d'autres groupes
notamment il swapo au nigeria et c'est
pour ça que la posture devient un
régional et on salue l'initiative
d'accra qui permet effectivement aux
pays du golfe de guinée burkina faso
togo notamment bénin de collaborer
ensemble dans la lutte anti de jadis
initiative dont quentin gaza n'ont en
tout cas bonne ou mauvaise en tout cas
ces salles existent qui reste c'est
quand même de hauts murs et d'eau doit
la côte ça veut dire on voit bien que
c'est un problème c'est celle qui est
peu par rapport aux objectifs qui donne
toute cette zone sahélo saharienne il ya
là grands acteurs masqués de la région
qui est l'algérie dont on parle peu
c'est à dire tout ça c'est comment ce
que ça va se faire les relations entre
la france et l'algérie par rapport au
nord au nord du mali qu'est ce qui te ça
commence qu'est ce qu'on sait pas trop
qu'est ce qui va se passer réellement
dans l'impression que la france descend
finalement sur les côtes à l'ancienne
voici meschia les russes les turcs les
chinois finalement eu ça va être aussi
l'occasion de dire d'augmenter encore
leur s à l'occasion ils sont déjà là
tout le monde essaie d'avancer ses pions
en afrique comme il peut et tout mais
finalement il ya une sorte de retrait
français donc et puis je sais pas
évidemment il faut juste par rapport aux
mouvements ou mondialistes donc on sait
déjà l'état islamique n'a pas de
capacité de descendre sur la côte sas et
voilà les djihadistes ne cherche pas
aller sur les côtes tenir les ports et
ça c'est pas possible pour eux ils n'ont
pas de quoi faire mais il ya une volonté
de on va dire d'harceler les pays du
golfe de guinée aux frontières pour
essayer de sanctuariser ce qui est tout
à fait normale entre guillemets dans un
processus stratégique cohérent pour
sanctuariser leur centre leur centre tir
normal y ait aujourd'hui on est dans le
centre du mali même eux mêmes les
djihadistes y disent que ils ont pas
assez d'unités disciplinée pour
répliquer ce qui a été fait au nord mali
et dans le centre burkina faso
par exemple donc c'est à dire pour
l'instant oui mais après voilà donc donc
la réponse donc juste pour vous dire
donc la réponse militaire qui a été
pendant neuf ans donnait sans capitation
politique d'ailleurs ne nous a pas
empêchés d'avoir se sentir aujourd'hui
donc maintenant ce qu'il faut voir c'est
comment essayer que c'est on va dire que
c'est de ne pas refaire les mêmes
erreurs avec les collègues qui ont été
faits avec le g5 un peu plus loin vers
la côte donc c'est ça aujourd'hui le
l'enjeu ça veut déjà dire un état
islamique prochainement peut-être au
mali tiens à dire que l'on oui c'est
l'un des scénarios les plus probables
c'est qu'en effet la junte malienne
fasse le lit des islamistes et qu'on ait
à terme l'arrivée d un arrangement entre
la junte et les islamistes et plus tard
des islamistes au pouvoir alors non pas
dans leur version
al-qaïda où le loup l'état islamique
mais plutôt dans leur version
politique actuelle c'est-à-dire l'imam
dicko et c est une confessionnalisation
du mali et de toute façon cette tendance
à la ré islamisation comme on dit est
une tendance de fond dans la région que
je manifeste aussi très clairement au
niger et c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas
croire que voilà il suffit de simplement
de se redéployer sur une deuxième ligne
pour dire qu'il va bien c'est une
deuxième ligne qui est aussi extrêmement
problématique qui sera aussi très
problématique pour les les autorités
françaises si elles continuent à gérer
cette guerre de cette façon agressive
surtout la rolls parle d'islamisation du
niger le niger qui devient l'allié a
pris mes bras n'ont pas enrayé la
mauritanie zèle république islamique de
mauritanie la mauritanie a eu une
problématique similaire avec al-qaïda
depuis 2011 ya pas eu un seul attentat
en mauritanie il ya eu des choses qui
ont été faites donc la force qui a été
utilisé mais aussi les voies de
négociation et les voix de continuer
charia dans la constitution beaucoup de
choses en mauritanie ya beaucoup de
choses et aussi la prise en compte des
autorités sur les sujets sécurité avec
très rapidement depuis dix ans la prise
en compte de ces sujets légers et six en
option
et puis effilée l'action il ya une
volonté des autorités mauritaniennes de
portée des services publics sur
l'ensemble du pays il n'ya pas de la
césure qu'on peut connaître aux
conneries mais j'aimerais quand même
rajouter mais le niger justement le
niger est également le mènera également
qu'un pays qui s'est saisi de l'aide
apportée et on voit bien que parmi
l'ensemble des pays du g5 il ya des pays
qui réussissent il y en a qui
réussissent moins donc il n'y a pas que
l'aide internationale qui rend causé
aussi la manière dont les pays sont
saisis de ce sujet et quand même deux
points importants dans ce qui a été
annoncé ce matin non seulement
effectivement il ya la transformation de
la nature de l'action militaire il ne
s'agit pas de refaire au niger ce qui a
pas super bien marché au mali d'une part
et d'autre part il ya l'implication des
populations civiles qui ne sont plus
considérés que comme des victimes et
compte que comme dire véritable rempart
de contre le djihadisme et donc c'est
les cas piliers de peau mais peut-être
avec davantage d'efforts vers le pid et
gouvernance et développement mais
lorsque thierry vircoulon parle
justement de cette possibilité
d'islamisation du niger aussi alors que
ça devient un peu l'allier aujourd'hui
de la france bat ce problème la france
risque de fragiliser le président bazoum
il faut le dire ça veut dire c'est vrai
que ça peut être fragile c'est le seul
président civil élu de la région il a
essayé de sun tous les autres sont des
militaires et ça peut le fragiliser et
pourquoi ce projet viserait en tant que
je disais parce que vous avez déjà eu
des convois de jeunes nigériens qui ont
aussi caillassé des convois de l'armée
française parce qu'il ya une tension
parce que bon on va pas rentrer choses
très précises mais le président ma une
base où il a passé il est quand il a été
élu quelques jours après son élection il
ya comme une déjà une tentative de coup
d'état dans son pays je veux dire c'est
c'est quand même craignos pour lui il
aurait jusqu'à il ya que grand frère
algérien qui peut protéger le risque
actuellement niger c'est en effet un
coup d'état comme au burkina faso et
l'arrivée d'autres colonel puisque non
en hauteur de vagues de colonialisme
dans toute la bande sahélienne où en
effet le pouvoir civil tomberait au
niger avec pax quand on parle
d'islamisation parle de ce qui se passe
dans la société nigérienne pas ce qui se
passe au niveau politique avec en plus
donc cette vague de d'islamisation et
tous les militaires qui arrivent au
pouvoir actuellement n'ont pas de
solution à cette guerre non plus et donc
c'est pour ça que après eux les
islamistes auront si je puis dire
après les scènes tirées vircoulon tome
agassi ou par dont 80 % d'après ce que
j'ai lu des éliminations de djihadistes
au sahel était le fait de moyens aériens
donc ça ça demande quand même beaucoup
de moyens compliqué est ce que
effectivement on va se retrouver avec
une menace djihadiste qui pourra aller
jusqu'à abidjan jusqu'à dakar c'est bien
le but justement de faire de réarticuler
nos efforts pour justement éviter ça
parce que moi je pense que la
progression de la menace djihadiste vers
les états côtiers serre c'est un vrai
risque est justement il faut l'anticiper
il faut permettre aux états qui ne sont
pas aujourd'hui pleinement touché 2 par
prévention de de les préparer à faire
face parce que par exemple au nord bénin
on a des signes inquiétants quand qu'on
n'observe progressivement et donc mieux
vaut prévenir que guérir j'allais dire
et il faut dès aujourd'hui que cinéma
engage mais comment ça va être des
forces spéciales afin que les caisses
des régimes c'est la réalité du terrain
il ya très bons rapports de mathieu
pellerin de l'ifri qui expliquait
problème entre éleveurs agriculteurs les
peuls dans les parcs animaliers c'est ça
le problème en dehors de le des
problèmes sécuritaires donc je dis à des
problèmes intercommunautaires il ya des
problèmes entre entre les éleveurs des
agriculteurs et à partir du mans les
gens vont dans les parcs animaliers pour
se nourrir parce qu'ils peuvent pas
trouver où se nourrir et communes et les
états prennent des sociétés sud
africaines de rangers et c'est pour les
chasser c'est des problèmes socio
économiques de base mais pour coup je
partage ce qui est dit et je pense que
l'élément nouveau c'est de ne pas faire
part aux pays africains que seul on sera
en mesure de résoudre le problème on
peut apporter un appui sécuritaire mais
la vraie résolution des problèmes ce
sont les états africains qu'ils ont eux
mêmes pour trouver des solutions
effectivement aux problèmes locaux qui
peuvent exister parce que c'est sur la
base de ces problèmes locaux que les
djihadistes prospère tiens à dire que
l'on va faire ça je dirais seul entre
lhimer les pays africains n'ont pas
c'est un discours qu'on leur tient
depuis 20 ans que ils ont la solution de
leurs problèmes donc ça n'a rien de
nouveau malheureusement et
malheureusement on ne s'intéresse ne
s'interroge pas beaucoup sur la
fiabilité de des gouvernements qui sont
nos alliés dans cp dans ces zones là
voir s'ils veulent vraiment faire le
développement s'ils veulent vraiment
résoudre les problèmes socio-économiques
dont on parle si ils veulent plutôt que
de bénéficier d'une rente de sécurité
vous parliez tout à l'heure de
d'appropriation en ce qui concerne le
niger de la sécurité enfin
l'appropriation qu'on a noté aussi au
niger ça a été le scandale au ministère
de la défense de détournements massifs
de fonds ou l'eau qui ont été révélés
par des journalistes d'investigation
nigérien qui quand ils ont protesté ont
été arrêtés donc vous comprenez bien que
c'est pas avec des partenaires comme ça
que le problème va se résoudre bien sûr
que la solution d'avenir 2 mais la
situation locale et elle en termes de
gouvernance depuis tellement longtemps
que il ne faut pas compter que ce que
tout d'un coup il ya un coup de baguette
magique et que parce que paris dépenses
quelques milliards ou demande plutôt à
bruxelles de dépenser des milliards dans
ses dogmes ça va résoudre les problèmes
wassim est-ce que ça va devenir une
poudrière jihadistes pour faire simple
après
écoute et ça veut dire il ya alors on
parle là par exemple l'état islamique al
qaïda se livrent une guerre au mali une
guerre sanglante on parlait du police en
civil qui vont être remparts mais c'est
le pressent civile qui on paye le prix
la haye des trois villages touareg qui
ont été vidées de leur population par al
qaïda les accusaient de travailler avec
l'état islamique une fois qu'ils étaient
dans la brousse à l'état islamique les a
attaqués les a massacrés en nous disant
travailler avec al qaïda donc les
populations locales aujourd'hui dans ces
zones de conflits se trouve obligé en
l'absence de l'état de choisir un camp
et les deux camps présents sont al qaïda
aux états unis ce qui reste neutre en
paye le prix donc on est dans une
dynamique aujourd'hui qui est qui qui
qui qui qui est pas nouvelle parce
qu'elle ait démarré avec la création de
deux amis quand 2015 et qui se greffe
sur les dynamiques les problématiques
locales mais que les groupes djihadistes
eux-mêmes essaie de dépasser pour
recruter plus large donner un autre
exemple très présents viennent à
recruter plus large oui al qaïda
parvient alors que tu es plus large ils
recrutent même chez les dogons
maintenant avancer russe et arabe
maintenant elle découvre chez les peuls
et chez les dogon c'est une dynamique
dans laquelle al qaïda s'est impliqué
parce qu'elle fait de la politique à l
inverse qu'est ce qu'elle promet
une justice notre survie et la sécurité
moi ça va pas plus loin ni droits de
l'homme on y voit là s'appelle sécurité
justice tu peut traire la vache
tranquille tu peut planter ton chant
tranquille et on va te protéger contre
les plus radicaux de l'état islamique
voilà celle ça va pas plus loin que ça
donc c'est pour ça que au sommet de
n'djamena le retour de l'état était un
des points majeurs qui était avancée par
la france que dès le sommet de peau
encore une fois eu les quatre piliers
donc je partage tout à fait ce qui est
dit et je pense que les autorités
françaises et le président mâcon partage
également ce constat c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on veut non seulement
transformé l'action militaire mais on
incite vraiment les états à faire des
réformes nécessaires avec le plus
inclusif possible dans leur gouvernance
pour que chacun se sente bien dans ce
pays et que chaque citoyen de ces pays
se disent je préfère aller dans le sens
de l'état que d'aller dans le sens des
jihadistes qu'est ce que vous pensez
atterrir colons de ce genre de jeu
pendant recommandations je pense que
c'est un discours qu'on tient depuis
cinq ans puisque la stratégie des 3d
elle existe depuis déjà longtemps
c'était du développement diplomatie et
défense et c'était déjà la stratégie des
autorités françaises qui disait voilà il
faut agir sur ces trois domaines on voit
le résultat aujourd'hui au mali alors
qu'est ce qu'ils proposent et alors non
mais ce qui est proposé c'est surtout
qu'il faut s'interroger sur cette guerre
qu'on fait et pourquoi on l'a fait et
vous qu'elle vient position comme vous
le disiez tout à l'heure est ce que le
but c'est de faire une guerre sans fin
où joue qui avec les chefs djihadistes
où on se dit c'est très bien au sahel on
va tuer on tue des djihadistes ont fait
des listes on l'est on les tue et donc
on a réussi alors qu'en même temps ça
détériore la situation sur le terrain et
ça montre les populations locales contre
nous donc est-ce qu'on va s'interroger
un moment dans ce pays et je le dis
parce que évidemment serval et barkan ça
et c'était contemporain des attentats de
paris du bataclan donc dans l'émotion
c'était normal que on la guerre contre
le terrorisme soit justifiée de cette
façon pour tout le monde mais 6 en sept
ans plus tard avec les conséquences
politiques que l'on voit de cette guerre
où on se fait éjecter du mali maintenant
et demain d'autres pays dans le sahel il
faut quand même qu'on réfléchisse aux
finalités de cette guerre est à se
demander j'ai hâte en un moment qu'un
gouvernement finissent la victoire dans
la guerre contre le terrorisme au sahel
qu'est ce que ça sera pour que l'armée
française 10 on a réussi et on peut
sortir je pense que cet élément a été
défini c'était de mettre les groupes
armés djihadistes à niveau des armées
locales donc de former les armées
locales et de désorganiser ces groupes
c'est ça l'objectif passe quel projet
c'était l'objectif final le rechercher
aujourd'hui malgré tout je partage des
constats mais je n'attends pas de
proposition et justement sur ce qu'il
faudrait faire cette réflexion est en
cours le présent vaincrons a lancé avec
l'ensemble des européens une refonte de
la stratégie en afrique de l'ouest et
d'ici cet été dans les prochaines
semaines s'était aussi l'objet du sommet
hier c'est justement de faire évoluer
les modalités d'intervention mais moi
j'aimerais entendre en tout cas dans
l'ensemble des débats qu'on a des
propositions justement sur quoi évoluer
sur quoi accélérer je pense qu'il ya une
redéfinition des parmi les quatre
piliers peut-être d'aider des priorités
parmi ces quatre piliers et de continuer
effectivement à inciter à la bonne
gouvernance à d'inciter à des actions
fortes en matière de développement
puisque l'action militaire ne sera
jamais en tant que tel suffisante en
quoi le gaz est vrai que ça ne marche
pas non mais il faut pas non plus voir
tous ces de cette zone comme une
poudrière etc je veux dire faux-pas faut
aussi savoir que en tout cas il ya
beaucoup on parle de djihadistes
djihadisme il ya vraiment des groupes
armés il ya scellés et état de trafics
en tout genre dans toute la région qui
profite à des tas de gens y compris au
niveau des dirigeants de ces pays
africains je veux dire c'est ça aussi
parce qu'à force de dire 'je alice on a
l'impression des gens pas rivaux dit oh
là là il va y avoir des centaines de
milliers de terroristes mais c'est sympa
même si c'est quand on mélange tout ça
veut dire les uns un français pour faire
court qui décide d'aller rejoindre
l'état islamique en série et de revenir
faire un attentat ici à paris le 13
novembre ça n'a rien à voir avec un peu
qui décide de rejoindre al qaïda au mali
et on peut pas tout mélanger maîtres et
langer même niveau un terroriste et ada
gallic est un homme politique à nos
tables et qui est sur liste pour être
éliminé aujourd'hui donc c'est ça il
faut 10 fait du discernement et essayer
de comprendre qu'au barca n'est pas une
opération policière il ya une
insurrection antérieure aux jihadistes
et ça est traitée en temps à être
traités en tant que tel avec tous les
leviers y compris celui de parler avec
ces gens d'ouvrir des canaux dernière
puisqu'il ne restera pas beaucoup de
temps est ce que la france finalement
fait partie est ce qu'elle se déclassent
finalement aujourd'hui ils sont un
certain nombre de candidats qui disent
ça deux candidats élections d'hier voilà
la france est beaucoup moins influente
qu'auparavant moi je te crois quoi la
france a montré qu'elle avait la volonté
de le courage de mener ce combat et la
d'amener avec elle la communauté
internationale que ce soit le nu les
européens qui aurait cru encore quelques
années qu'on aurait été capable de faire
quelque chose comme takouba la france a
montré sa capacité à être nations cadres
et à aligner les européens vers des
positions et donc je pense que si tu à
kouba et démonter aujourd'hui au mali
l'esprit takouba restera rare et qu'on
va faire des belles choses en tout cas
on saura tirer les leçons de tout ça
pour faire mieux dans les années qui
arrivent en collaboration avec les
autres églises air d'optimisme et les
russes les chinois je suis dit je
voudrais parler aussi des autres à
commencer dans une ambiguïté total c'est
de la france d'hier ne pas être en
première ligne c'est fini la
françafrique et cetera mais finalement
la france et nations 4 c'est la france
qui décide de tout en tout cas c'est ce
que disent les autres européens quand
euros aux russes et aux chinois c'est
très clair ils se sont répartis au
niveau de la prise des russes sur la
sécurité informationnelle et puis les
chinois font l'économie le business
c'est ce que raconte mes copains en dans
les villes et en centrafrique les
chinois au fonds d'infrastructure et
puis les russes la sécurité et pis les
mines parce que ea il faut c'est un jeu
de go on en ukraine c'est avec vladimir
poutine s'est vraiment les joueurs
d'échecs en afrique c'est les jeux de go
ça veut dire c'est l'opportunisme et ils
vont faire les coucous en centrafrique
ils vont mali et à bas prix et en plus
c'est dit se paye avec ses la diplomatie
qui est autofinancé à partir des mines
d'or en
somalie et ça sera les mines de diamants
centre accueille donc la france là
dedans il faut prendre nous la caution
de l'afrique de la mondialisation de
l'afrique la mode à liège zones
d'afrique l'a fait la france les [__]
sol il faut donner l'impression qu'on y
soit toujours tout seul dans la région
elle est plus seul du tout wassim al
banon vient jeu est ce qu'elles ont
perdu du terrain c'est ça la question il
ya un jeu de compétition aujourd'hui où
en fait il ya une contradiction il ya
une contradiction pour que les gens en
tout cas c'est perçu comme une
contradiction par exemple les gens sur
place moi j'étais à gta nouakchott j'y
ai passé une semaine on a vu pas mal de
représentants africains j'ai même pu
m'entretenir avec le colonel aux aguets
etc ils comprennent pas pourquoi la
france soutient débit le fils débit et
disent pourquoi lui et pas nous très
clairement donc c'est la guerre des
c'est la guerre des perceptions donc
même quand il ya des efforts
multilatéraux pour faire entrer l'europe
externe pour l'africain pour les gens
là-bas pour les populations c'est la
france qui mène la danse sauf que la
france ne mène pas la danse la part de
ben je n'y arrive pas et n'en tire aucun
profit donc on est vraiment dans une
situation assez assez cocasse
aujourd'hui la france est le genre
d'homme les autres sur le business
cyrille coulon d'accord avec ça et les
russes alors donc ils sont opportunistes
et donc maintenant comme il ya une sorte
de nouvelle guerre froide avec eux ils
utilisent l'afrique comme un terrain
d'opportunisme et et on se demande
d'ailleurs si on est antoine disais tout
à l'heure c'est un nouveau monde etc on
se demande si on va vers un nouveau
monde où si on revient aux années 60 qui
était une époque où justement à cause de
la guerre froide et bien certains
régimes africains avaient choisi le camp
soviétique et notamment le mali avait
mis fin aux relations avec la france et
donc je ne sais pas moi si on va vers un
autre 21e siècle ou si on n'est pas en
train de revenir aux années 60 une forme
de régression non il ya des cycles en
fait effectivement la russie était très
présente en afrique et notamment au mali
dans la période post coloniale
effectivement lors de l'effondrement de
l'empiré soviétique la russie s'est
totalement retiré aujourd'hui
effectivement l'afrique re devient un
enjeu de puissance on l'a vu en libye
ont leur centrafrique au mozambique
aujourd'hui au mali et donc français et
européens il faut qu'on arrive à à être
dans ce jeu-là a montré à accompagner
l'afrique vers des pratiques de bonne
gouvernance vers la vers la sécurité et
à le faire au profit des populations
civiles c'est quand même ça qui nous
distingue la sieste et wagner et là bas
pour des questions de ressources
financières par les mines parce que leur
donne les gouvernements ces
gouvernements peuvent pas payer 18 ils
devront servir directement sur la bête
comme il en centrafrique en confisquant
on va dire le retour des douanes on y
est dans quelque chose de beaucoup plus
positif antoine glaser vous concluez est
reçue il fallait convaincre alors oui
simplement encore une fois il faut y a
une histoire et à une histoire entre la
france et l'afrique on est sorti de la
françafrique d'accord mais on a
l'impression parfois que la chute du mur
de berlin on a bien vu la réunification
l'allemagne la fin la guerre froide on
doit bien en europe mais on a
l'impression qu'on afrique on commence
simplement à le voir merci beaucoup
antoine glaser merci thierry à vircoulon
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous
thomas gacilly merci wassit mois-ci
manas merci à vous tous genres suivi
reste avec nous sur france 24
[Musique]